[Music]
[Music]
hey you guys kind of went out a couple
minutes early because tom was just like
let's get it
it's way too long
people wait too long yesterday we were
saying we were going to watch uh
superman four because we had it you have
all i have we have all launched i even
have like uh the new superman uh the
reboot the rube the the most recent
reboot is in there it's like all five of
them
for the old ones and then like the one
that i forgot this just got man of steel
which i've seen it once it is okay um
but uh it's hard to beat chris reeves
and uh i saw
quest for peace
first time i saw they was on hbo or
something
and i was just going through the damn
channels
and i watched like five minutes of it
and i was like man this [ __ ] [ __ ]
it looked like [ __ ] it does it looked
like [ __ ] on a damn television of the
day too look like it was almost what the
hell are you doing
it looked like a damn made for tv movie
but um
just saw it last night again i saw
access this is the first time i watched
it in its entirety same with you huh
i think so yeah
and it looked a lot better than i
remembered it i think it's because the
new television so that we see it now you
know kind of like probably the way it
would have looked if you if you'd gone
to the theater and saw it
i don't know if this had a theatrical
release or if it was direct
it did okay
there's a lot of weak spot parts in the
movie some of the shots are bad but and
some of the
the script kind of
missed the boat
in several places there's some [ __ ] they
could have done
was a lot better than i remembered it
it's a lot better than i remembered it
it's um it's entertaining it's bad and
it's like stupid as hell but it's still
like kind of entertaining to watch we
did like we had a couple drinks and
watched it and we were just like
cracking up the first two are
masterpieces and then the donner cut of
part two is [ __ ] even better i really
like the donner cut too
um
the third one
unfortunately not too good it had a good
cast richard pryor was in it
that one should have been really good
but it had a different director and it
really wasn't
i actually like this one better than
three
some people do um this is a pretty
universally uh [ __ ] on movie and for
good reason
but there are some people that are like
well it's terrible but it was better
than three i think it is
um i haven't seen three in a long time
so i don't i remember liking three when
i was a kid
um
but
i don't know i mean this one
this three looked better yeah it was
shot a lot better well this one was just
so um
cheap yeah because what happened i mean
i don't know if people like know what
happened with this superman franchise i
mean the first two obviously were
massive hits the third one
not so much
so uh the producers the saulkind the
saulkind salkin however you pronounce it
they didn't really uh they thought that
the franchise had run its course
and so they basically sold the rights to
cannon yeah canada for five million
dollars and it failed um and canon you
know if everybody that knows like all
the cheap ass action movies like you
know missing in action and all kinds of
stuff
uh yeah they're basically known for
making really really cheap ass movies
and having a whole bunch of them going
at one time
so what ended up happening with this the
only reason actually after canon bought
the rights to do superman they were like
ooh this is going to be our biggest
movie ever and they thought because
canon was having financial problems at
that point and they thought and they
needed a big hit
um you know so they wouldn't go bankrupt
a spoiler didn't work but
the only reason they got christopher
reeve to be in this because after the
third one kind of flopped uh christopher
reeve is like yeah i don't really want
to play superman anymore but cannon told
him
not only will we give you six million
dollars like salary will also let you
write the script and have uh you know
say over how the script goes and who the
director is and they also said that they
would fund his
the kind of smaller art house movie he
wanted he wanted to make streets street
smart uh so they actually gave him the
money for that so that's the only reason
that he agreed to do it and him agree
him agreeing to do it got like most of
the other actors from the original
movies back on like on board yeah now
it's probably a good move to put him in
in charge had they put random
[ __ ] in charge there it would
have been that story would have been
even crazier
oh it and actually this story is good it
just didn't they missed he they missed a
lot of things that could have been done
that would have made it even better
okay
um
but i i think maybe budget got in the
way
at least they got they got a good cast
they got the right they got the the real
superman theme music they got the rights
to that
it's
the way it was shot was kind of spotty
some of it looked
terrible and a couple shots the green
screen
you know really really looked bad other
stuff looked pretty good
um depending on what the situation was
uh during the final fight on the moon
there was a there was one shot where uh
atomic man [ __ ] punches nuclear man
nuclear man punches superman he goes
flying off his this damn [ __ ] red
nuclear [ __ ]
little electric bolts going around him
and they show him go by kind of like in
slow motion and zero g and it looked
good looked like something out of them
ghostbusters you know kind of like
ghostbuster one level uh uh
animation it wasn't really anime it was
look the special effects were animated
but it was just a shot of [ __ ] reeves
going by
some of the wire work was pretty good
um it looked terrible on television from
what i saw
but um
on a new hd
tv and dvd format looked pretty good
which is what it would have
what it would have looked like uh in the
theater it's just that it was kind of
inconsistent
um well yeah and honestly uh okay so
like i said the green screen was
terrible
uh the original canon originally said
that they were gonna have 32 million to
make the movie but then they cut the
budget in half
so a lot of the special effects team
couldn't really do what they wanted uh
they couldn't afford to film in new york
city like the other superman ones so
they actually all of that was filmed in
england
um even like the u.n building uh all the
kind of stuff that was supposed to be
new york a lot of that was uh milton
keynes in england it was good enough
they just kind of like you know threw a
hot dog cart on there but you know
obviously it's not new york
superman is um from new york no i know
metropolis but that's i know but you
know more convincing that much that new
york can make some more convincing
metropolis
yeah but uh yeah but so yeah so they
couldn't afford to shoot in new york so
all of it was done in england yeah um
the first cut of this actually i did
this is kind of interesting the first
director that they were talking about
uh was wes craven
okay uh but him and christopher reeve
didn't get along so christopher reeve
said yeah i don't want i don't want wes
craven so they got sydney fury instead
uh who had made the ipcress file in the
uk i think and uh which was actually a
good movie but what ended up happening
um there's a lot of [ __ ] that was cut
out of this
because the theatrical cut that we
watched that's only like 90 minutes
right yeah uh the 40 minutes was cut out
of that i wonder if it's available
including it might be on the dvd you
should check um but there are because
i've seen uh you know some other reviews
of this where they had a lot of the
deleted scenes
one uh kind of plot point that was taken
out was that lex luthor
made a nuclear man before that nuclear
man like he made one and it was and it's
ridiculous looking it looks like
um
kind of like frankenstein's monster but
like a really really cheap glam version
yeah
like you know what i mean it's hard to
explain that would have been cool but he
had like spiky hair like black spiky
hair and he just looked and i guess like
it didn't work out right like i guess
superman killed him so
makes more sense so that whole thing was
taken out yeah um some scenes were taken
out that made stuff in the movie not
make sense okay like especially like
some [ __ ] i mean it's still i as far as
i know like the long version still
doesn't really make a lot of sense and
still has like a bunch of plot holes but
they made it worse by cutting 40 minutes
out because i guess they showed it to
test audiences and there was a bunch of
stuff that test audiences reacted badly
to
so they took a bunch of stuff out and
that made some stuff particularly toward
the end where um where what's her face's
character the the newspaper related
what's her name uh marilyn anyway oh i
don't remember what her name her
character's name character name was yeah
i don't remember either
lazy something like that yeah but um
the whole thing with like nuclear man
wanting to kidnap her which kind of just
came out of nowhere right uh there was
actually a little bit more setting that
up like he had actually met her you know
before and it wasn't a thing because i
think like the way they have it in the
movie now it's like superman's like
you're never gonna find her and it's
just like this is the first time that
she's ever mentioned that it's mentioned
that she wants that he wants to kidnap
this woman or whatever so i kind of feel
like that came out of nowhere plus
there's like really dumb [ __ ] in it like
um you know where nuclear man like takes
what's her face and flies her into space
and she can still like breathe and i
don't notice that
i guess something like breathe and then
superman like brings her back and she
doesn't burn up on reentry or anything
like that it makes me absolutely realize
that it happened but yeah
i mean we were pretty drunk we were
watching this but it was a good time
that's why it was the movie's fun
yeah i mean the drunker you are the more
fun it is yeah but um
i mean there was some good [ __ ] about it
but then there's just like some like
what the [ __ ] like what was that
about like lex luthor
inexplicably dancing with a woman he was
dressed like cleopatra what no no no not
no it was like a no
like marie antoinette and there must
have been some that was and it wasn't
brought up again yeah at first i thought
it was miss tesbacher but it wasn't
yeah and then he just pays her to leave
you're like what the [ __ ] was that about
it it's like it's not friday because
before it's set random but um it's
it's still a fun movie i still enjoyed
it more than three
uh it's
the the the for me the main problem with
this movie is
the opening
title
[ __ ] um credits you just look at him
you go this looks like made for
television movie yeah like a tv i was
reading something i watched like the
nostalgia critic did like a big long
thing and chris stuckman did a
hilariousity review on this and they
were basically they were talking about
how the opening credits look like
the windows xp movie maker version like
like
like it cost like a dollar fifty yeah
what were they thinking because the
first impression that's [ __ ] very
very bad
and then a few minutes into it i'm like
this isn't that bad
and i'm like it's a lot better than than
than the opening credits had me believe
they should have just done a very stock
kind of generic superman flying through
the damn
grand canyon the [ __ ] mom american
pie apple chevrolet [ __ ] type even
though it's all set in england yeah but
it doesn't matter she just doesn't even
even the farm right like even that farm
was in it is in england but you didn't
need all that going through space in the
[ __ ] title you didn't need that they
should have done that
like just a regular helicopter shot
stock going through the damn
grand canyon that would have made a
great
background and then just put some
[ __ ] titles on there and instead of
trying to do fancy titles like the other
ones just real basic and it would have
been it would have been very passable it
would have been a
if you can't do high-tech do basic but
just do it well and people will buy i
mean the whole thing is about canon i
mean it's a superman movie you need to
have good visual effects for superman if
you can't afford to do that and you're
not
willing to like put up the money to do
it right
then don't do it because it's just going
to look like ass don't look like ass
and even the first two they went around
certain things
they went around certain limitations of
the time they were expensive movies but
you couldn't just show any old things so
they kind of created how they went
around the technological
limitations of the time
now let's get to um
some of the good things about the movie
is that there's some [ __ ]
real good
chris reeves superman isms you know what
i mean like he just saves some [ __ ] from
a disaster in the subway
system and he pops out and tells
everybody in the crowd how how awesome
and safe the new york subway system is
even though he does in london too
actually
[Laughter]
yeah that's okay it's just a movie
but he comes out and says that [ __ ] is
that's like some superman would do do a
goddamn public [ __ ] safety awareness
[ __ ]
class in the middle that's like some
[ __ ] boy scout [ __ ] the superman
would do you know and uh there was just
a lot of things that i think reeves did
well
with you know um well i mean he did okay
with easily the best thing is the best
thing about it and his script was
good good not great
good a little bit of a mess
well i better if i'd seen the original
all of it because i don't know like it
should have been that less luther's
first
nuclear man failed that's kind of in
line of
what a comic book story would be the
first one comes out and it's not that
good and it's kind of like
what back to the drawing back to that
yeah and it was played for laughs right
right you know that's actually how it
went and that's kind of like more like
something you'd see in an old school
comic book yeah uh where
uh the first nuclear man shows up and
superman easily defeats him so
so luther's got to go back and [ __ ]
come up with something better which is a
build up to the main dude
this is where the script [ __ ] falls
short and i started coming up with this
[ __ ] and jane's like yeah yeah and she
that's how it should have been and she
starts throwing in more stuff
first off
the big weakness of this
is that nuclear man as a character
has no character
he should have been
an important character in the story
maybe reeves didn't want the the uh the
spotlight stolen from from him
but how it should have gone was this
the second nuclear man gets made and it
should have been made with good
technology not the [ __ ] technology
that was shown in this
technology
we're gonna put dna in a nuclear missile
and [ __ ] and and and superman throws
the nuclear missile into the end of the
sun and he comes out fully formed
knowing who he comes
no well he comes out like a um
like a like a fetus yeah and then like
he grows in well did was there something
in there where lex luthor said he was
putting some stuff in there that would
make itself into clothes yeah which i
guess it kind of just but it's yeah
i thought i remembered something like
that i was kind of drunk though they
were trying to guess explain that why
they were indestructible
okay
but
that's a very bad idea all right it
should have been something that would
was grown
in a vat
with some nuclear material involved with
it and it's its growth was accelerated
it had some [ __ ] to do with kryptonite
probably or something the krypton sun
and then it comes out he [ __ ]
brainwashes it quickly with kind of like
one like one of those damn green
crystals that [ __ ] superman had yeah
maybe he steals it from the fortress of
solitude or something
and uh
[ __ ]
me or or maybe a super computer okay
okay
he uh trains him with a high speed
supercomputer
so he knows what only what [ __ ] um
what luther tells him
then he starts fighting superman
and then he finds out that superman and
him are related because he's made from
his dna
so then nuclear man goes wait a minute
superman's my brother
and then he finds out that [ __ ] they
came from another planet krypton and
that krypton's gone
all right so then there should have been
this thing where
nuclear man is trying to hang out with
superman to become a team
all right you know like join me you know
type of deal and together we can bring
back krypton
and where you can but then it turns out
it goes wrong where is krypton going to
be made it's going to be made on earth
yeah that's what that's what i would
have done and then the deal was this
nuclear man should have said you take
lois and have children with lois and
i'll take the maryland hemingway chick
and we'll have and i'll have a child
with them yeah because there would have
been a reason for him like wanting her
then right and then i'm just ready and
then we'll recolonize
the [ __ ] planet planet earth with
kryptonians and we'll repair your beings
yeah and and then you to use look at how
they're handling the nuclear issue these
[ __ ] are going to destroy each
other with these nuclear weapons that
that type of deal okay which is you know
that mankind is violent and inferior we
got to get rid of them and put good
people on there and with genetic
engineering we can revive our species
that would have been a much better story
now the whole thing about
superman
just
manning up
and deciding the nations of the world
are there you guys are full of [ __ ] i'm
going to take all the nuclear weapons
and throw them into the [ __ ] sun no
more all your toys away right
that would have gone directly against
[ __ ] what his [ __ ] dad would have
told him in the damn crystal all right
to he said don't interfere in their
politics don't become a god to them
that's one is that was one of his
[ __ ] instructions well he did learn
that at the end of this movie to be fair
yeah and then
if he probably should have done
something like that just for the movie
all right in the beginning part
but in reality would have made the
situation worse that's why he should
have [ __ ] it would have made it worse
because what would have happened is that
soviet union the united states could now
go to war with one another but it'd be
conventional like yeah that wouldn't
conventional warfare because now there's
no nuclear threat to keep them from
attacking no mutually assured no mutual
destruction
so the the evil hairless monkeys gotta
kill they're like [ __ ]
we can now go to war
because woohoo everybody
the nukes [ __ ] prevented the war okay
so then
which if super superman was too smart he
would have known that though so it never
would have [ __ ] happened right in
that end of the story is kind of dumb
superman would have been like no they
this is what is enforcing this forces
the peace
but anyway let's say he does do that he
gets rid of the nukes the united states
and the [ __ ] soviet union now go to
war which justifies what nuclear man is
saying
see
everything all the plot threats would
have tied in together instead of just
being random [ __ ] that would have been
proof that nuclear man could have come
and said said [ __ ] kalel look you
took away their nuclear weapons and what
do they do they don't [ __ ] want peace
they want war they gotta go
we gotta we gotta get rid of it it's not
just the nuclear arms that were causing
it it was their nature their nature is
evil and that would have made a lot more
sense and it and you probably could have
[ __ ]
some of the action that you would have
shown would have meant more in the movie
some of the stuff that was shown
they showed it to you just for the
[ __ ] well that's just a show well
what i was what i was trying to get out
sorry i was laughing at grantham's
hammer because he said i would have been
cool with having a child with muriel
hemingway in 1987 hubba hubba yeah
although they put terrible aerobics
clothes uh honor but everybody looks bad
in those it was impossible to look good
in this what could a rover's closing
there i don't know if it was those high
five things
so [ __ ] unflattering but yeah see the
problem i had with the movie like i said
christopher reeve is great he's always
great as superman he's like the
quintessential superman there's never
going to be a better one sorry um you
know gene hackman was fun in it he
wasn't in it enough for me but whatever
um
margo kidder was good in it she see a
couple of scenes seemed like she might
have maybe been drunk i'm not entirely
sure um but she but her and christopher
reeve have such a good chemistry between
them so that like whenever they do a
scene together it's always like really
good now if this was me
um like you said i would have made
nuclear man more of a threat i mean the
dude is not threatening um the outfit
wasn't terrible uh they probably looked
okay they probably could have made it
look a little more badass but i mean him
doing stuff like standing in the middle
of the street just going
yeah i will hurt people i'm like that's
really not you're really you're really
not selling it you're not selling no he
should have been
kind of like a mirror image of superman
he should have been [ __ ] reasonable
and [ __ ] uh kind of intelligent but
evil and evil you know or at least uh a
lot of
hubris or something like they gotta go
you know the humans are bad you know we
need to bring back krypton here on earth
yeah i mean that would have made a lot
more sense he didn't really have any
motivation of his own he was just
mirrored and even his voice was dubbed
over that was gene hackman's voice yeah
um they even dubbed over his that
actor's voice his name's mark pillow i
think yeah um and like i said he wasn't
even the main like you know because they
had another guy earlier and all that
dudes scenes
for 87 the the bad guy design
looked look oh look good for 87. yeah
for 87. that was that's what they would
have come up with it was just it that
character didn't have any character he
was more like the hulk just running
around bashing [ __ ] and even the hulk
had more character yeah so like i said
he didn't have any motivation of his own
right which would have been interest
like i'm not saying that lex luthor
couldn't have created him but i think it
would have been better if it was like a
frankenstein's monster situation where
he created him to do his bidding but
then he's like no no way i'm going to do
my own [ __ ] and that would have been a
lot more interesting so it got out of
lex luthor's control i think that would
have been really cool yeah um i also
think they could have left muriel
hemingway in there just as something
else
but i think they should have focused
more on
nuclear man um and on
the villain and him having a character
and them like fighting because some of
the fights toward the end were kind of
lame
but
i think they could have completely
gotten rid of
the subplot with the newspaper being
taken over by that rupert murdoch
type of dude um you didn't need that um
you know you could have brought meryl
hemingway in some other way because she
didn't it's just a girl working at the
office right it didn't really have
anything you know that didn't tie in
with the larger story also could have
done without the the love triangle
quadrangle situation they didn't really
need that they could have had a little
bit of that they did it because it was
cheap and yeah um you know yeah you
could have brought the muriel hemingway
character in and yes nuclear man could
have like
you could have seen her and fallen in
love with her or whatever and we're
going to like repopulate the earth and
making a new krypton so yeah but she
could have introduced her a different
way without all that other subplot type
of [ __ ] and you didn't need
i don't know and it seemed too that like
uh
superman's powers in this were
inconsistent yeah like it you weren't
supposed to do yeah like uh nuclear man
like [ __ ] up the great wall of china
and then superman is able to like just
look at it and it builds back he fixes
it with his eye lasers somehow he never
did that [ __ ] before and also the one
scene that they ripped off from the
first movie where he was flying with
lois lane
um he let go of her and she was still
flying yeah yeah yeah she flew along
next to him for some crazy ass reason
and then so that was bad enough but then
they take muriel hemingway into space
yeah and she can like breathe and see if
and her head didn't explode or she
didn't have a suit on she just had a
[ __ ] regular 80s like office wearing
yeah now one of the one of the things
that
i mentioned uh what i told jenny the
night we were watching it is it said
that a good superman story
there's always has to be a scene
where
superman's purity is tested okay they
didn't really have this a real
significant scene like that in here they
had some they might have had one of them
or two of them but they didn't there
wasn't a lot of impact
nuclear man once he [ __ ] put it down
the deal about hey
we can repopulate the earth and make new
cr make new krypton again and you can
finally marry lois
see
superman should have been tempted by
that for for for a few minutes he'd had
to shake that off
like
yeah because because look at how bad the
humans are they're going to war with
each other yeah
now that you took the nuclear weapons
away they're doomed they're not going to
live yeah look you were trying to help
them yeah and they're doomed and they're
not going to last anyway
so let's go ahead and get this over with
and [ __ ] let's make and
it should have been a scene there where
superman
was gonna do it
but then he he somehow she shakes itself
out of it but there has to be like a
meaningful scene where something happens
that reminds him of something what his
dad told him
you know what i mean about it's not his
honest he said he had to go back to the
[ __ ] fortress of solitude and talk to
his dad
they didn't have brando in this one they
were his mom was in it but and then
brando should have said some my son you
can't believe and kryptos are long gone
that kind of [ __ ] you know i mean you're
it's not it's not your place in the
universe to be deciding what species
survives and dies that kind of survives
it should have been like a
a moralistic
[ __ ]
answer to [ __ ] superman's [ __ ]
problems where he was like yeah that's
it no no i gotta save the earth
krypton's gone yeah i mean pretty much
something like that i mean pretty much
the only moral questioning that he had
was like near the beginning
when the thing that that makes him like
that's the catalyst for him getting rid
of all the nuclear weapons which like i
said very very simplistic yeah because
you know childish yeah everybody knows
that that [ __ ] you could just make more
yeah and it's like and how does he know
and it and it was funny too like that he
just goes to like the u.n or whatever
and says hey i'm gonna get rid of all
the nuclear weapons and everyone's like
yay i'm like that's that's not how that
would go but anyway um but the the whole
catalyst for him doing that
was a letter from a kid
so it is actually childish reasoning to
say oh well now that we don't have
nuclear weapons anymore suddenly like
world peace is you know it solved
forever which obviously like i said
wouldn't work out and to the movie's
credit it does kind of sit it does kind
of imply that superman sort of learned
that toward the end but he does kind of
question when he gets the letter from
the kid about hey superman why don't you
get rid of all the nuclear weapons yeah
he does actually like child solutions it
is well yeah literally in the movie so
at least so at least they knew that much
i don't think they were that self-aware
but um it does kind of seem like well he
questions whether he should do it or not
but not because he thinks it's not going
to work because he thinks that he
shouldn't interfere because they told
him not to so he does go to the fortress
of solitude and ask the elders about it
or whatever and they give him a [ __ ]
in in kind of a [ __ ] nebulous [ __ ]
you know they they kind of condemn him
don't they
that one man you should put it all on
one man type of deal yeah i mean they
basically tell him don't do that
and then he i think he talks to like um
he talks to lois too yeah and she
basically kind of hedges around the
question by saying well you'll do the
right thing you always do the right
thing yeah oh she lit put it on him
don't ask me i don't [ __ ] know yeah
i'm just i'm just a chick that works in
the newspaper just like don't put that
much pressure on me like okay super
alien but uh yeah so so they could have
done that um the whole thing about like
i said i like the idea
of making a villain out of superman's
dna i think that's a good idea um i wish
they would have done it better than gene
hackman
and his stupid nephew
waltzing into a museum in the middle of
the day yeah um breaking open the thing
with one piece of superman's hair which
is holding up a thousand pound weight
and yet he can still cut it with bolt
cutters or hedge clippers or whatever
those were um so he takes that and like
an alarm goes off but no security guards
come running nobody sees it there's no
cameras that might be a reality though
maybe not what city you're i don't
really know well yeah it's supposed to
be metropolis which supposed to be new
york city i'm like i can assure you if
you go to like the met or some [ __ ] in
new york you just get too close to a
painting and [ __ ] the guards are like
hey what are you doing quit breathing on
that you know what i mean or like an
alarms go off and stuff so
so i mean it would have been better if
they would have shown them like breaking
into it but like i said maybe that was
expensive also
uh look i love john cryer as much as the
next person he was great as ducky dale
and i called him ducky dale throughout
this whole movie while we were watching
it but i really could have done without
that character lex luthor
and i mean what i mean the way he talked
in this it was a choice i'll i'll say
that much yeah oh no
yeah
i was writing it up i was like stop it
yeah he was happy
he was like so i was so embarrassed for
him yeah and
gene hackman was doing a pretty good job
but they they were directing him to just
ham it up even more the movie was kind
of tongue-in-cheek
yeah the first two that got the tone
perfect
you know yeah it had funny [ __ ] in it
yeah but it wasn't it wasn't like a
comedy
now
with all the other stuff that was shot
and with modern technology i know you
could fix the opening
credits that's that'd be easy to fix
little tweaks here and there
and a re-edit with the other stuff you
might be able to make this into a good
movie today
just with what's that well just just
with the deleted stuff you could it's
not that bad
it's not that well i feel like there's a
good idea in ideas in there it's just
that
the story should have gone the way me
and jenny said it should have gone
that's how it really should have been
but but with what they have you could
work with that too
it would just be stuff would have to be
cleaned up i would be interested to see
if someone uh you know had the time or
the wherewithal to do like a fan edit of
this
and clean up the special effects because
it could be done you know fairly easily
it would be time consuming sure
but
you know maybe somebody could do
something with it because like i said
it's not a terrible idea all around
um i think it's better than three also
nuclear man needs a better more badass
villain name yeah i can't i can't think
of one
but his ass nucleon or [ __ ] i mean
something i mean nuclear man is just so
half-assed yeah it's just they weren't
even trying they weren't even trying
this like nuclear man i don't know
you know
whatever
it's just like
grifter's hammer says i made two
villains out of my dna one is eight
years old the other's ten
that's right
your kids are villains the whole making
of making a another superman out of
superman's dna that was also done in the
animated uh feature a red sun yeah
that's right where which is very good by
the way real good you should see that
one it's an anime animated movie much
better than this one oh yeah um
and um a lot more has a lot more the
tone of the the first and second movies
and it's kind of like a what if story
what if superman landed not in the
united states but in the soviet union
back in those days what would it be like
if he was raised as a communist
and then what would it be like if batman
was also in russia now that's it that's
in there too because batman's in it
russian wonder woman's in there too
didn't she yeah but she's still from
isle of lesbos she's unchanged yeah but
but um
yeah they got russian batman's in it
it's called red sun
s-o-n yeah s-u-n and you should see it
and in that one
lex luthor is actually kind of like an
american hero it's like an alternate
universe and he's
working to protect america the american
oligarchy really is what it is
against the threat of the soviets
so luther
gets some superman dna and does some
stuff to it and creates a clone
um
but it's he's beaming some kind of
energy to it remember that there's some
kind of wave like the more you give it
the bigger the bigger and stronger you
get it's kind of like
kind of like [ __ ] cellular steroids
the [ __ ] are turning up the
thing and you get some cellular energy
to [ __ ]
like cell phone his [ __ ] steroid
level goes up and he is right now
and he sends him to go suit to fight
superman but he's if he's like a failed
experi he's a he's a failed experiment
he dies
but it's kind of like
that sounds like the scene that was cut
out of this movie
yeah where they made kind he made the
first nuclear man that didn't make it
and that's if in red sun you'll see that
story although like i said the deleted
scenes in this one it seemed like that
was mostly like real jokey it was a joke
okay um like it's it's real stupid
looking like the first nothing against
the actor they did they made him do that
but um because i've seen him in other
stuff but yeah so the thing about
nuclear man too is that
you know the suit was fine uh it wasn't
that silly but he had those big long
silver lee press-on nails yeah yeah yeah
and uh you know
like i said he wasn't like he was real
dumb and he wasn't real intimidating uh
they had and he didn't really i mean
because they didn't fight and because
they had some kind of you know whatever
explanation that because he had the same
dna as superman all that he had to do
was was scratch superman in the neck and
it made superman sick like it gave him
the flu and like made him get old and
stuff yeah it gave him like radiation
poisoning because he was nuclear man
even though he came out of the sun oh
and also
um a little bit of a design flaw but
nuclear man was solar-powered so if he
like stepped into a shadow he just like
powered down yeah he kind of falls so
all you'd have to do to fight nuclear
man is just drag him into like the shade
yeah and then beat his ass yeah but
superman didn't know about that
yeah superman didn't know but i'm just
like some i mean because they even say
that like lex luthor is like yeah well
it's if if he doesn't like
he's not like right in the direct
sunlight which happens in the movie like
he is in the shadows but he's still
doing [ __ ] but that seems like a pretty
bad weakness
uh you know well yeah well he had to be
definitely inferior to superman yeah
they had to make sure that that would
and then like but he just did like
random [ __ ] like he pulled the statue of
liberty off the thing and just flew
around with it
and um then he like made a made a
volcano go off in italy somewhere and
superman and that super plugged it up
here's the thing which uh that would
probably make it worse i would think i
give this movie the prize also he moved
the moon yeah he moved what you did
moving on i don't think that would go
like you would expect i give the movie
prop
the movie was extremely ambitious
yeah
some of the [ __ ] that superman's doing
he cut the top of a [ __ ] mountain off
using laser beam eyes
picked it up and flipped it upside down
the top of it and used it as a cork to
plug a [ __ ] volcano volcano and it
looked okay
[Laughter]
for 80s you know for the 80s for cheap
80s for cheap 80s
it was very entertaining it was it was
uh
like i said very very ambitious i
started i started channeling like all
the girls from the carrie locker room
plug it up plug it up yeah that's funny
of course that wouldn't work volcanoes
happening way deep down it just would
have blew around it you know that's
that's what i'm saying it's like that's
and all the italians are like oh thank
you superman and then they're like now
it's gonna be even worse because there's
like this big piece of rock there that's
gonna blow up and like kill everybody
yeah and then he goes down there and
[ __ ] saves pompei or whatever it is
by [ __ ] blowing he gives it a [ __ ]
lava it was it was it was fun though
that that is the kind of [ __ ] that was
in the old comic books yeah so it is
kind of true the [ __ ] source i think
that that's how superman actually ended
up saving muriel hemingway who like i
said can live in space but that's
something that a lot of people didn't
know about her
maybe he was making a force field around
him both so he could take him through
space you'd have to go to the source
material maybe he did that in the comic
books
i don't even think this came from a
comic book previously i mean i think
that there was a comic bookization of it
after the movie came out but i don't
think this was based on
or at least it wasn't based on like a
you know
chris reeves wrote the [ __ ] i think he
would have [ __ ] have known whether or
not superman could take somebody into
space
it might have been innocent comic books
that yeah he did take some people into
space because
during the time superman first [ __ ]
first [ __ ] appears that's [ __ ] was
the 20s 20s or 30s yeah i think it was
30s [ __ ] they didn't know what outer
space was i mean [ __ ] you got [ __ ]
flash gordon run across the wing of a
spaceship opening
opening the window to a rocket ship and
shooting the [ __ ] gun out of the dude
[ __ ] standing on the wing
so you know i think it was kind of like
that they didn't know well [ __ ] you even
saw that up into the 50s yeah like in
this little really cheap jack sci-fi
movies with like people walking around
on the outside of the spaceship yeah
without any [ __ ] helmet on they got
this yeah and if they do have a helmet
they open it up talk to somebody
[Laughter]
it's just got a window that it could
go out of space like that
that's just like really funny but that's
that's how he saved marilyn hemingway is
that because nuclear man was flying with
her out in space taking i don't know
where he was going to take her but
now that i'm thinking about it where
were they going i don't know
um
yeah so he was just flying with her out
in space and then superman had figured
out well he figured out that he was
solar-powered so he's like oh well all i
have to do is like put him in shadow and
he's useless
so he moves the whole moon yeah oracle
said why couldn't you just like throw a
blanket over him right you could but
it's just like a little just like a
horse or a chicken or something you
threw a blanket over me they're all like
dude i never i i never really got
i never really got the idea that
superman um
knew about that weakness though i don't
think he ever even confronted it did he
yeah he did because that's why he moved
the moon that's how he moved that's
that's why he moved the moon he moved
the moon in front of the sun oh that's
right to make the [ __ ] to make uh
yeah which like i said that would have
caused complete like cl climatic uh
chaos on the earth yeah you'd have had
all kind of like tide problems [ __ ]
tidal waves
everywhere and everything [ __ ] like that
it would have been a disaster thinking
about it too much i well well i'm
thinking about it more than the screen
writers thought about it well and like i
said i was it's a funny ass movie yeah
but
all the [ __ ] that's in there
you can make like a superhero movie like
people with magic powers and [ __ ] like
that obviously yeah but
you can't get away with that kind of
[ __ ] not today not today um because
people are just too savvy yeah you can
do supernatural [ __ ] but you have to
have a plausible sounding explanation or
people are just not gonna buy it they're
not going to buy it well it was 87 and
we don't and it's but you got it it was
1987. it was canon films okay you got
chris reeves writing
and we don't know if chris reeves is
trying to play an homages to old [ __ ]
comic books where anything could happen
because the original source material
anything could happen
think about it yeah we're moving the
moon yeah we can move a moon that's fine
well he was standing quote let me quote
quote standing end quote in space yeah
on nothing and when grabbing a rock and
throwing it
turning the rocket around like he's
standing on something and then throwing
it like that he
you you grab the rocket and you start to
turn the rock around you would
turn because you don't have enough
massive to [ __ ] turn it down rocket
it's just funny
well
another thing too is that where did he
get that big ass net that he put all of
those nuclear missiles in you weren't
even supposed to
ask that the only scientifically
accurate thing because we were thinking
of we were thinking about this the only
scientifically accurate thing
is that probably
you could take all of the nuclear
weapons on earth and sling them into the
sun and nothing would happen like this
like the sun would just be poof it
wouldn't even notice it yeah it probably
wouldn't even throw the earth into it
and it would so yeah so that was
scientifically accurate that he threw
all the bombs in there and you know and
nothing really happened other than poof
well that was probably exactly what
would happen yeah well there was an
explosion
on a surface and you wouldn't even
notice that probably yeah that's what
i'm saying so that's pretty much the
only scientifically accurate thing this
it
you can throw the entire earth
into the sun and then it suddenly
wouldn't even notice it
yeah it is like nothing everything can
be vaporized yeah but yeah so i mean but
all the other stuff i mean the movie
doesn't know how space works it doesn't
know the moon works it doesn't know how
dna works
um
you know but like i said if there's a
good idea in there yeah um i just feel
like
they just had to change focus they
should have changed focus gotten rid of
the whole like other newspaper subplot
because that didn't mean anything that
didn't tie in with the major with the
major storyline
um so get rid of that subplot it was
useless get rid of the love triangle
type thing largely didn't need that uh
because they spent a lot of the movie on
that yeah there was a lot of girl
problems superman's girlfriend yeah and
then and then like goofy [ __ ] like oh
here's this one like you know uh lois is
gonna interview superman
while muriel hemingway whose character
name i can't remember is having a date
with clark so now it's like this wacky
farcical kind of thing where they have
to like oh well now superman's going oh
gotta go to the bathroom you know what i
mean so superman can come back in the
other door and it's like they spent sand
just like you know and superman like oh
i'm gonna cook this duck that she has in
the oven it's like they spent too much
time
on that kind of stuff yeah and only one
man has successfully done that howard
hughes
date date two women at the same time in
the same restaurant in two different
tables not knowing not knowing those
girls not knowing that he was dating the
girl on the other side what did he say
did he tell him he had like irritable
bowel syndrome and he had to keep
running off yeah his secretaries keep
calling him that he was wanted on the
phone
because they have cell phones back then
i think that um i would have started to
get suspicious
yes every every 15 or 20 minutes they
call him on the phone and he'd be gone
for 15 or 20 minutes and then he'd come
back 15 20. so he but he was walking to
the other
the tables couldn't see themselves
because it was a big rotational
restaurant right and on the top of a
[ __ ] building he had to get up
through an elevator and then he he
reserved tables on opposite ends of it
and in the center of it was a central
hub in the kitchen so they would never
see each other and and
evidently the way it was set up the
bathroom was rotated too so there's no
way there was no way or there was no way
that they would ever see each other i
mean wouldn't it just have been easier
to make the dates for like a few hours
apart he was he was 20 something he did
it on purpose well that's what i'm
saying yeah he must have done it just
like to see if he could do it yeah it's
a challenge yeah because i'm like yeah
it's pretty easy to be like hey i'll go
out with this one friday night at 8 00
pm and that one friday night at 10 p.m
or whatever and that one's saturday
night it's like you didn't really have
here they were just they were actresses
they were like famous actresses young
famous ad from the studio that he owned
so it's not like they could do anything
to him if they got caught
yeah that's true there had been no
repercussions they would have got fired
that's what would have happened
yeah so it's like moved so that i can i
can treat you halfway once yeah
yeah they worked in his studios so he
could do whatever but yeah so yeah so i
feel like the movie spent too much time
on that
when it should have done like i said i
like the idea of lex luthor
you know having the dna and making the
nuclear man who should have a better
name yeah but
that character should be built up more
he should be more intimidating yeah um
he should have been smarter yeah
he should have named himself maybe maybe
[ __ ] [ __ ] called him nuclear man
but once he got smart about krypton and
[ __ ] he came up with like a much more
badass you know he called himself a
krypton name yeah like sael or some [ __ ]
like that yeah see that would have been
really cool and then he adopted his own
krypton name and he's trying to bring
back krypton see it's making another
superman it's making an evil superman
yeah so there has to be and it's out of
his dna so he has to be high quality
yeah he can have a weakness because he
can't be the real superman
but he's got to be able
but mentally he's got to be formidable
yeah because i fee i feel like him
having to be in direct sunlight that's
like to that's too weak of a weakness
yeah i think it's two weeks of a week um
because we just had to because like
oracle pointed out you could just throw
a blanket over the dude yeah should have
been something to be abused he should
have had the same weakness as superman
had kryptonite
and when that ma and what that meant is
is that somehow superman was gonna
figure out how to use kryptonite against
an enemy
yeah that would have been good too
because then he yeah he had to use
something that was also harmful to him
to the other guy yes and that's now you
got something to work with in the story
yeah see all of that superman gonna deal
with kryptonite right and you and get
somebody right well how would you do it
you'd use lois
yeah you'd have lois set him up
with the kryptonite that's how yeah see
like i said everything and then lois
could be the hero see yeah
yeah and that would have like upped her
character too like had her do more
things right instead of just like you
know getting flown around
yeah so that's how i would play that
see they need me to do this [ __ ]
well i mean it's really it's
storytelling 101 it's like well it's
screenwriting what 101. it's like if
you're going to make a decent movie you
can have subplots and [ __ ] like that but
everything has to tie together there
can't be [ __ ] in there that's just
random no and to me it just seemed like
there was a lot of random [ __ ] in this
movie that with a little tweaking like
we said could have been tied back into
the main story and it would have all
made sense and been cohesive yeah but
they didn't really do that yeah cohesive
and it all been self-supporting and then
when you got done you'd be like oh man
it was a satisfying movie and you really
wouldn't and i could have done it on
that budget that they should that they
had i could have done it at that budget
and i would have had less fighting
special effects and put the money into
fewer scenes but a lot more attention a
lot more acting a lot more storytelling
and then you do have a couple scenes
where some fighting goes down and save
your money for that
you know
i kind of feel like too another thing
that you can tell that this really
didn't have the budget was the scenes of
christopher reeve flying like from the
front yeah they're not quite as good um
they're all the same they're the same
ones okay they're all it's all the same
shot of him flying over different
backgrounds okay um if you didn't notice
yeah and that seeing it toward the at
the very end where he flies up over the
earth and then like looks at the camera
and smiles yeah they ripped that off
from the first movie that's the exact
same thing i remember i said that yeah i
said isn't it the same shot that's why i
wanted to tell you that is the same shot
they just they just tweaked the color a
little bit so it looks a little bit
greener than the original one which was
more on the blue they had all already i
guess they had the rights to do it
though huh
i guess
they did it they got away with it yeah
but yeah they definitely used that same
shot of christopher reeve flying from
the front and they just pasted it over
different backgrounds now they did have
some wire work a [ __ ] reeves doing
his wire work his [ __ ] landing is
superman he was always good with on on
on a wire yeah and it still looks pretty
good so it looks good
a lot of the shit's passable
it's only like a notch under the first
two movies in most of the scenes some of
the [ __ ] is way under
i will say that one scene of superman
and nuclear man
and they fall off this building and
they're and the green screen looks
really really bad
it reminded me of um have you guys seen
the movie from the 50s beginning of the
end about the giant crickets
yeah yeah or locusts or whatever where
there's a scene at the end where it's
very very obviously crickets climbing up
a postcard yeah of a building like a
picture of a building yeah um the this
scene of like superman and nuclear man
reminded me of that because it was like
obviously them green screened in front
of
a picture of a building in new york
because they didn't shoot this in new
york so all the new york footage was
either like b-roll
um or stock footage
uh because they shot the whole thing in
england so you know some of this like
shots i think from above in new york
they either bought them or they there
was another crew that that had them and
like attributed to the movie but
yeah but that really reminded me of
beginning in the end with the crickets
crawling up the postcard
in the beginning of the movie there's a
little establishing uh stories of
superman saving some cosmonauts and [ __ ]
which it wasn't bad it's just that there
was something about the edit it didn't
quite have
the charm appeal of some of the stuff
that used it's almost kind of like there
was too much footage there and that
could that little story could have been
shown in just a couple shots i think uh
so it's weird the proportions of
the edit the proportions of how much
they used how much film footage and time
they used for this and then how much
they used for that and this
the proportions are kind of off yeah i
think that's exactly what my problem
with it was right it seemed too much
that too much there's too much of this
and there's not enough and not enough of
that much of this none of that that's
what i was saying there wasn't enough of
the villain there wasn't enough of like
the main conflict and there was too much
of this other stuff like about the
newspaper and about the love triangle
and the goofy [ __ ] it's like you could
have had a little bit of that but
it seemed like it was disproportionate
yeah and so then when it came time to
for him to like fight the nuclear man
thing it seemed like kind of a wet fart
because he hadn't really been in it that
much
um up to that point so it's just kind of
like it seemed like they were just
tussling around and then they were
tussling around on the moon and then he
was dead you know what i mean it's just
it seemed like very anticlimactic we get
back to it again
it's a shitty [ __ ] movie but it's
very enjoyable
it's fun to watch for sure it's fun to
watch i liked it better than part three
uh is it a good movie no
could with everything that was shot i'd
like to see what what wasn't used like
the stuff from the from the wall yeah
you should look on the blu-ray because
it's probably there i bet you you make a
badass fan edit with this and it'd
probably be a good movie now i'm kind of
curious probably he's done that now it
would be retro it'd be retro superhero
stuff but i think if you did the edit
properly you could did certain things
the right way
you could re-jigger that [ __ ] story
and with the right
right soundtrack in the back of it clean
up some special effects throw a lot of
the bad shots out
probably make a [ __ ] pretty cool flip
yeah as long as the [ __ ]
tempo of it and the the cadence at which
it goes is good and natural
you could probably make it feel a lot
like one or two
yeah cause like i said i don't think
it's an irredeemable movie because like
there there's a good movie in there
somewhere yeah it's just i think that it
was edited weird some of the dialogue is
stupid and can be taken out some of the
like scientific stuff is questionable
and could be taken out or like retooled
they used shots that they didn't have to
use but they used them anyway they
didn't look good yeah you know but it
could be fixed yeah it could be fixed i
don't know if it could be fixed
with the existing footage um but i don't
i don't know maybe you you might be able
to like add some stuff steal somebody to
steal some stuff that was thrown out of
the other movies even yeah you could do
that maybe and then you [ __ ] use
filters and effects to make the make
the grain of the movie seem a little
more higher end
uh there are some shots look better than
others some of it looks grainy and low
quality some of it look almost looks
like
[ __ ] video some of it looks like it
was shot on video it's not it's film but
the film quality looks inconsistent as
it goes yeah some shots look real good
some of the interior shots art deco
designs at [ __ ] at at uh like
mexico's place some of it looked good
yeah that actually looked really nice um
it's just uh
it needed work it just needed more work
but there was there's a d there was a
good movie in there if you had the edit
right yeah
yeah kind of a shame it's kind of a
shame right kind of a shame that
christopher reeve that this was his last
appearance yeah superman yes kind of a
bummer it was a shame that he didn't see
the potential like we said of what maybe
he didn't want to be upstaged by the
villain i don't know i would have
written a [ __ ] better villain
yeah it's like a more interesting
villain yeah because he just seemed like
a dumb just like like a big hulk dumb
yeah like he didn't actually the hulk is
more interesting yeah but because at
least he kind of has a personality of
his own he doesn't just go around going
with big long nails and stuff
it's just that seemed like really i
don't know um but yeah so it
you know like i said it's kind of a
shame and i i understand like why
everybody shits on this movie it is
still entertaining
um i recommend it but it's not it's not
good but honestly
um it you know even if you're any kind
of like you know filmmakers storyteller
if you write novels anything like that
in a lot of ways i think it's more
instructive to watch bad movies than
good ones yeah you want to see something
that's done
not bad but with something that has
mistakes in it and think about it and
yeah and because you know if you like if
you like superheroes if you like
superman you like the very first movies
you can see what went right in the
first i'm going to call them two and a
half movies because the donner cut i
have that too so that's almost like
another different another movie another
it's a different version of
part two but one and two and two and a
half i thought they were great
masterpieces really
uh in a certain way and a certain one
definitely is
um for the first one
and then you
three i just didn't like it it's just
hard to really get a feel for three
uh
it's just
too
it swings too far in the comedy
direction
i want to see it again yeah i wouldn't
mind see it watching it again but but
four i liked it better than three
and
four could have almost been up there
with three had the edit been right and
the writing been better
and
i think me and jenny have it have it
down
had the story gone yeah i think our idea
would have been a lot better
it would have been it maybe would have
saved the franchise it all made sense
it wasn't long after this
reeves got thrown from the horse and his
head hit the damn standards in the
[ __ ] or the uh well that was several
years after this this was i think that
that was this came out 87 that was 95 95
was that much later yeah because
somebody could grant there's hammer just
asked was this his last movie before the
horse riding accident yeah and
kanavatsan said no that was village of
the damned which came out in 1995 and it
happened in 1995. i haven't seen that i
want to see that uh it's it's all right
i didn't love it um i haven't seen it in
a long time i didn't realize it was that
late i didn't realize that it was that
late that it was 95 yeah that happened
yeah yeah poor guy
i know that was like awesome
the stem cells would fix it and [ __ ]
spinal break man that's that's a wrap
the only thing you know what you know
what could do that nowadays maybe
some kind of [ __ ]
computer
yeah you know what i mean in the center
there you have like a cpu that does a
bunch of [ __ ] processing because
computers are badass nowadays they might
be able to figure out how to line up all
that stuff yeah re-route it nano
technology going out in there i don't
think you'd do it with biology you could
probably do with [ __ ] technology but
because this would be kind of a simple
wiring rewiring program
to somehow get them oh yeah i don't i
don't have any doubt that they'll
probably figure that out one of these
days you have a super computer in there
figuring out trying to figure out what
what the what neuron is supposed to
connect to the other neurons on the
other side and do trial and error over
time the computer figures out
what runs what
had to be it had to be ai basically
yeah i don't know but you could probably
do it
just take time but that's decades away
probably yeah
louie asked did you guys see the
documentary of superman lives the one
where nicholas cage was supposed to play
superman never saw i i didn't watch it
but i do remember hearing about that and
i have seen the photos yeah of nicholas
cage like in the superman suit i would
like but it could have either been it
would be the most awesome thing ever or
the most terrible thing ever but also
kind of awesome in its terribleness it'd
have been terrible and i love i love
nicolas cage but
i don't he i don't see him as superman
though no
i've seen shots of
what things were going to look like you
know what i mean [ __ ] flying skulls
and then just the way it was gonna it
was real tim burton-y
and uh nah
yeah i'm not real sure that would have
worked out i just would have hated it i
can't remember like what year that was
even supposed to come out telling y'all
what's going to be good well they say
the new the evidently the new spider-man
that's out right now they say it's a
[ __ ] masterpiece
and these are harsh critics saying that
guys are guys that [ __ ] hate
everything you know well they hate
everything they like what i like they
don't like they hate everything they
[ __ ] hate everything they like what i
like and they [ __ ] don't like the
[ __ ] that i like the guys that i trust
you know what i mean uh reviewers uh
they say that the new spider-man is
[ __ ] great they say that that it
might save the superhero genre in the
films because they had the same
complaints about the mci mcu that i had
that it was just generic as [ __ ] you
know
but evidently man i got a feeling that
new batman's gonna be good i think the
trailer looks good i think it's gonna be
really good
and then you're gonna have [ __ ]
a little what's her name being like kind
of like an eartha kitt style
catwoman she's going to be that's going
to be good within uh kravitz yeah zoe
krabs
she looks great in that catwoman outfit
um and it's just kind of in the
batmobile looks like a [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] soup duck i don't know lincoln
town car or something just
look at something out of mad max just
kind of like a a real gritty
batman he doesn't look like an unlimited
money batman it looks like a [ __ ]
something that a dude could reasonably
make in his house
and um
it just looks [ __ ] good man i just
i'm hoping that i'm hoping that what
they did was
is that they looked at the joker
you remember the joker
and said okay let's do that with batman
that's kind of the vibe i got from it
yeah oh bless you
she keeps chasing me if there's a chance
that that joker could be in this batman
oh it'd be knocking it out of the
[ __ ] park
well there are gonna be like joker
acolytes in this because i saw it in the
trailer yeah so but i hope it's the
joakim phoenix joker imagine that yeah
if they're smart that's what they did
that they make a whole new universe
they might they might be i'm not really
sure and you gotta do it right and you
don't kill the joker we'll keep leaving
alone she's going in the bed they're so
stupid every time they put joker in a
movie they kill him
[ __ ] [ __ ]
don't kill the joker he's the best
villain
joker doesn't get killed in a bad manner
she gets away and he might get killed at
the end
or something but no joker gets away
because you then now you're most of your
super villains get away they don't kill
them
we'll be able to kill them i mean that's
yeah i mean you kind of need i mean you
have a superhero they need a nemesis
yeah and the nemesis needs to be a
threat yeah so you can't just be like
poo and like kill them and then it's
just like they weren't any threat then
no in a good in a good comic story
the super villain
his plans are foiled but he escapes yeah
so he's still out there to come up with
another better yeah they don't see him
for a long time
and there'd be another villain that
appears yeah i mean see they're they're
on rotation
basically
i'm revampier says hey jenny and tom i
haven't caught you all live in a while
all right go ahead and send us that
super super chat
you're shameless
i was glad to hear about your new house
congrats on that oh thank you very much
yeah we're uh trying to close this [ __ ]
next month trying to close we're going
to close it next month yeah hopefully
it'll it'll all go it'll be okay says
that we need another bright burn movie
yes we do we need i really liked
breitbart yeah bright burn was really
good i don't have it i need i need to
get that one uh that was
and uh
they hinted at the end of bright burn
that there was more bad guys
yeah driving from space or something
yeah
grandfather's hammer says uh christopher
reeves was in a movie called somewhere
time uh yeah i've seen that with jane
seymour uh he corrected it later filmed
on mackinac island michigan at the grand
hotel every year fans of the movie still
meet at the hotel and have a convention
i didn't know that uh i saw yeah that
movie was on cable a lot back in the day
i remember uh
you know i remember seeing that and
actually quite like and although i
haven't seen it in a long time
mike says why can't superheroes just go
on a picnic when there's no villains
that sounds
can i just do one thing without a
villain a super villain popping up
everywhere i can't even have one [ __ ]
day where i can do my laundry
yeah that's weird because bright burner
from what i remember breitbart did well
at the box office that it made money why
haven't they made uh
another one in that um in that universe
it doesn't have to be that particular
character
if that was evil superman then then
you'd have an evil batman or you'd have
an evil
um
aquaman or whatever
oh evil aquaman i'd like to see that be
kind yeah
evil aquaman would kind of just
be kind of like creatures from the black
lagoon or something yeah see that'd be
that'd be badass yeah why don't they
make another creature for the black
lagoon movie
it's implausible
i don't get a lot of shit's implausible
they don't think people would go
superheroes are implausible yeah
[Laughter]
i can suspend my disbelief yeah i don't
know why
yeah there hasn't been a there hasn't
been a not really i mean they don't
really
i don't know i just i just feel like
you'd be cool he was like a really cool
character and honestly like when i
talked about like right around halloween
i talked about um monster squad and i
was talking about how cool that creature
from the black lagoon design that they
did for in that was
and i was just kind of like that seems
like the best one and they haven't made
a movie they make 40 bajillion like
vampire movies like dracula's and [ __ ]
like that come on yeah
i don't know morbius looks good it makes
sense now it's got morpheus or morbius
morbid morbius that looks really good
morpheus is a different thing yeah
i'm not real familiar with it i just i'm
not either i think
i think in some ways in order to kind of
rate and enjoy these things is to not be
all that familiar with them because i
noticed that real hardcore fans get
[ __ ] bent out of shape
if it's not if if some obscure element
of somebody's version of that character
isn't addressed you're like well come on
man there's about 30 different supermans
depending on who's writing
there's a you know a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ]
batman's
just because your favorite author really
isn't being addressed then you know that
doesn't mean it's not a good movie you
know it's just yeah i think it's better
to just assess the movie on its own
i mean is it a good movie it's i'm not
real worried about whether it's like
super accurate or not right now i'm i
get i kind of
yeah i mean i do kind of get panties
it's not so much with uh comic books
because i'm not really a big comic book
person but you know if i you know if
there's like a novel i really like and
they made a movie about it and it's
cheese and they changed too much [ __ ] or
i think it's stupid the changes they
made yeah i'm gonna be mad but
i mean i'm not gonna get too bent out of
shape about it because like i said
they're two different formats um you
know [ __ ] that works in a book doesn't
always work in a movie and vice versa so
you know so i understand they have to
change some things i really i'm glad i'm
happy with the [ __ ]
mandalorian as it is
uh i hope that that [ __ ] continues
evidently book of boba fett's going to
be pretty good is they started to show
those yet i thought that they were
either that it either just started or
it's going to be starting really soon
because i thought i remember like seeing
something trailers look good that's
that's star wars i mean they have the
ability if they want to to let star wars
be star wars stop trying to make star
wars something that it [ __ ] isn't and
that was the reason why those last three
movies sucked so bad
so i saw the solo movie
it wasn't bad
it wasn't bad it just wasn't great it
wasn't super memorable yeah it wasn't
super simple
and it was it didn't really need to be
made because we already kind of knew
that most of that story
um
and they got the wrong dude to play
[ __ ] solo there's a dude who
they had picture they had videos of him
doing it doing han solo from home
i think he was trying to get that role
and he could do [ __ ] harrison ford's
han solo to a [ __ ] tea
and it wasn't where he was doing a
cheesy impression like somebody doing a
cheesy impression of shatner
i don't know the guy's name uh but
people like why didn't they hire that
dude to be solo that he looked just like
him he could act just like a young
[ __ ] um
han solo
the the facial expressions the voice
everything and they didn't put him in
there they put another guy they put
aaron eric right or whatever that
fucker's name is these these
they're trying to get name recognitions
out of this [ __ ] stars that don't
have any name recognition to begin with
just pick a name just
just pick a dude
who is as good as the original actor and
looks and is reminiscent and can do that
that role it doesn't matter if that
guy's famous or not just put him in it
he can do it but you know they're trying
to give their friends work you know if
you ask me it's
politics they're trying to give their
friends the work not people that really
should be in there
but um
the solo wasn't bad just wasn't great
and then
the uh [ __ ]
rogue squadron was great i liked road
squadron it was good what rogue one you
mean bro one i mean yeah yeah i really
liked rogue one actually the problem
with rogue one is that everybody gets
killed in it because they have to
spoiler alert
[Laughter]
but if you know the story it's like you
know they're over there you know they're
all good enough no i have to die because
they because they said that they all
died to get the damn [ __ ] plants yeah
so you know they're gonna die
that was the problem with that movie
because any fans that you made you
basically lost them because there's no
reason for them to return back to that
story
and
if you look at the [ __ ]
data and data trumps data with evidence
trumps any emotion
if you have a character in a story who
gets killed
unless unless they've been in there for
a long time but if they die in the same
movie that they appear in their action
figures don't sell
they'll sell a little bit but not much
it
the ones that the ones that sell are
ones the characters don't really get
killed at them and that's and there's
data to back that up but in a way i kind
of like that they went that way with
rogue one because you don't really see a
lot of big tentpole movies where
everybody dies at the end so i kind of i
was kind of into that i thought that was
a good artistic choice not afraid not a
good business choice obviously but uh i
think it made it a better movie that it
showed how high the stakes were yeah but
they had no choice yeah just doing that
story meant that that was gonna meant
that yeah that everyone was gonna die at
the end but it also meant that the
action figures didn't sell and none of
those our action figures really sold in
the numbers and rogue one wasn't really
geared toward a younger audience anyway
i feel like not a kid's audience no but
the kids aren't buying those actions
that's true that's cool
that's another thing that's [ __ ] up
disney and these guys these are old
people making these decisions and
they're they haven't really quite
wrapped their mind their heads around
the modern world they make these [ __ ]
things they say well we're gonna make it
for kids because we can sell all these
toys kids don't give a [ __ ] about those
toys they don't give a [ __ ] about those
kids don't play with toys they play with
[ __ ] laptops and little little
[ __ ] cell phones and and [ __ ]
it's our generation bought toys and now
that they're older they buy they called
collectors action for collectors figures
and they don't want a [ __ ]
five dollar [ __ ]
toy to bubble back they want to buy a
200 [ __ ] accurate fully posable
action figure a [ __ ] luke
from [ __ ]
a new hope
and they'll buy six versions of that
[ __ ] depending on what clothes
he's in you know it's just they do it
there's a whole line of [ __ ]
action figures that are like that
they're like a couple hundred bucks and
they look [ __ ] awesome
and it's every goddamn character from
the original trilogy
they look great and then i think some of
them
of the uh
of like from [ __ ] phantom menace and
the other you know the prequels they'll
sell too
so that's where the market is now it's
not these little bubble pack toys you
know they didn't make any money they
lost their asses on all those
because they made so many of them and
they just sat on shelves
because
kids don't care about that
they'd rather have a video game grab
theirs hammer said did the trailer of
the north man play when you were at the
movie theater it did not uh robert
egger's next movie oh
i'm gonna have to like uh look that
trailer up because yeah i'm all about uh
robert eggers yeah we're gonna have to
see that one
uh five thousand dollar pokemon card to
look at i just don't understand
all right so uh how long we've been
going on oh my god we're long enough
hour and fifteen minutes yeah we gotta
we got to go out tonight so i kind of
want to maybe hopefully get in a nap
before i have to start getting ready
because i just i slept in this morning
like i tried to because i said well i
know we have to go out tonight so i
don't want to get up too early but yeah
like you know i still wake up early
whether i like it or not so uh yeah but
we'll be back tomorrow tomorrow we're
going to be talking about
identity because we watched that as well
uh because rob sent it to us so that's
the movie we're going to be talking
about tomorrow uh so thanks everybody
for dropping by and hanging out with us
we'll see you guys tomorrow afternoon
bye